you've uh talked about being vegan and i
don't think i heard you
explain this because it connects somehow
about how you think about life
so you talk about when your family is
good you grow that like circle of
empathy you grow the community
is that how you think about
being vegan
that
just the capacity of living beings on
earth to suffer
that you just don't want to
add suffering to them yeah i mean
you said it clear
it's like nothing
in all reality
i came to a realization that nothing
really has to die for me to live yeah
no animal the plants
themselves right so let's just say
you know
you want a steak which is probably the
most you know
you know i don't know the most expensive
piece of meat but let's just say the
steak is you know top of the line nice
steak yeah and you eating the steak for
the protein to help build your muscle
and i don't know if you got it from a
cow or a bowl but whether it's a cow or
the bowl they grow to about 1500 pounds
and if it's a ball it's all muscly
muscle
and it's only eating grass
yeah
yeah there's there's yeah
it's possible to uh both as an athlete
and just as a human being to perform
well without meeting meat that's
something
especially in the way we're treating
animals
to deliver that meat to the plate i
think about that a lot so i i do i'm a
robotics person ai person
and i think a lot about i don't know if
you think about this kind of stuff but
building ai systems as they become more
and more human-like
you start to ask the question of are we
okay
if we give
the capacity for ai systems to suffer
first to feel but then to suffer
um to hate and to love to feel emotion
how do we deal with that
it starts asking the same questions you
ask of animals
are we
are we okay adding that suffering to the
world right
and i don't think we should add the
suffering because it's not necessary
like look if it's necessary right
because we're
you know survival or the first law of
nature self-preservation
if you are in a desert and there's
nothing else to eat with that lizard
yeah yeah okay you gotta do what you
gotta do this is gotta go yeah you gotta
go you gotta do what you gotta do
because at the end of the day man is
when they say man has dominion over
these things
his dominion is almost like a caretaker
how the way we do our dominion we
dominate it eat it cook it yeah like who
who who's the first guy that looked at
the lobster
he was like i'm gonna eat this thing
he's like it's first of all it's hard to
eat it yeah you got to go through a
process to get that a crab i remember we
see crabs when we was kids and i didn't
know why i was always getting itchy
throats and all that you know you care
you don't know just eat but at the end
of the day a crab didn't provide no more
than
a finger worth of meat meat yeah
and it was hell getting that steak
getting out
it's like it's not worth it in all
reality you could have gave me a
you could have gave me
a banana
and did better for my body
and my appetite
and my being fulfilled that's full
like look look at the blessings
of of of of life right
if you take a seed
or you get an apple and you eat it
in that apple is multiple seeds in it
if you plant that seed it'll give you a
whole tree
with a whole bunch of apples with all
multiple seeds
but if you kill a fish
it can't reproduce done yeah if you kill
a cat it's done it's not it's not
they're coming back but when you deal
with the plants
even after you eat the apple
and then you defecate
your defecation is what feeds the ground
the cause of apple to grow more yeah
it's a circle of life and especially
there's a there's a guy named david
foster wallace he wrote a short story
called consider the lobster if you
actually think philosophically about
what
from a perspective of a lobster
that's like symbolic or something
because you're basically put
in in the water like cold water and then
it heats up slowly
until until it's no more torture yeah it
must have been like
they started eating lobsters in the
inquisition yes yeah yeah they just
enjoy so they will probably enjoy
torturing animals and they realize
they're also delicious after the torture
is finished that's probably how they
discovered it
you